The Republican governor
of Florida making news
today, Ron DeSantis.
His administration is blocking
a new advanced placement
or AP course
on African-American studies
in high schools.
Here's what the State
Department of Education
wrote in a letter to the College Board,
which administers AP exams.
Quote, The content of this course
is inexplicably contrary
to Florida law
and significantly lacks
educational value.
No mention
in the letter of what
law would be violated by the courts
or what is in the curriculum
was objectionable.
But a DeSantis spokesman tells CNN,
of course, quote,
excuse me, leaves large, ambiguous gaps
that can be filled
with additional ideological material,
which we will not allow.
Joining me now
to CNN political commentators
Bakari Sellers, former state
representative of South Carolina,
the Corey Sellers
podcast, also former Trump
campaign adviser, now
a supporter of Ron DeSantis. David Ervin.
Bakari, what does it say to you
that the administration is specifically
excuse me, coughing
doesn't identify
what part of the course they object to?
We're talking about
an AP African-American studies course
Well, Anderson,
I actually think they said
all they needed to say
and they said
this African-American studies
course doesn't have any value.
You know,
I've been speaking to my friends
about this via text, etc.
and one of them
just recently texted me
that they're trying to erase our history.
And that's exactly
what they're trying to do.
I mean, this is anti intellectual ism.
This is anti-black racism.
This is systemic
that when we talk about systemic racism
and this is exactly
what we're talking about,
it's the way by which we go about
ensuring that people cannot learn
about the plight
and burdens
that African-Americans in this country
went through and go through today.
I don't know what voids
Ron DeSantis is talking about.
I haven't seen the curriculum,
but I'm actually
an African-American studies major.
I'm actually the son of someone
who was a director
of an African-American studies
program at the University
of South Carolina, who,
oh, by the way, was a member of Snake.
It happened to be shot
in the civil rights movement.
And so I just think it's a damn shame
what Ron DeSantis is doing,
but nobody's going to stop him.
Because they are afraid of
what may be next for Mr.
DeSantis.
David, obviously there was a lot of talk
about critical race theory,
and that was a focus of a target
in a lot of states by Republicans.
This is African-American studies,
which is different.
A Democratic Florida state
senator tweeted
that Florida currently has AP classes
for European history,
Japanese language
and culture, German language
and culture, Italian language
and culture,
as well
as Spanish language
and culture, adding, quote, It's
the quote.
It's crazy
how AP African-American studies
made the chopping
block in Florida to that.
What do you say?
Yeah, so, Anderson,
and to Bakari as well.
Bakari, I did. I did.
But believe it or not, read
the 82 page syllabus today,
which I could send to you.
And the letter
that was sent to the to the AP board
says, listen,
we dismiss
this as presented in the future.
If the
if the College Board
like to work with us on something
which would meet
our criteria,
we'd be happy to consider it again.
And from what I was told, Anderson
and Bakari,
that this was declined
because it sought to teach
progressive doctrines
such as intersectionality
and critical race theory,
which are violative of April 20, 22
who are the governor to stand to set this
anti woke act?
I'm not you know, I'm simply telling you
what I've not delved in
and read every
you know, every chapter of the syllabus
but I glance through it.
It's pretty it's pretty dense.
And I'm telling you
what the reason was that
the state of Florida,
Governor
DeSantis said
they believe in education
and not indoctrination.
But what do you make of that?
I mean, it's ridiculous.
I mean, I have a great deal of respect
for David Urban, but,
you know, we just got done celebrating
Martin Luther King's birthday.
And you have individuals who
who say these quotes of,
you know, the
I Have a Dream speech, etc.,
These famous quotes by King,
but they don't even know who he was
because we don't teach the history
correctly.
People whitewash his legacy.
They don't talk about the fact
that he was a rabid revolutionary.
that he was talking about wages
improving the plight of black folks
day in and day out.
And I think that the fact
that we refused to teach
the accurate history of this country,
we refused to talk about April 4th, 1968
where Dr.
King was assassinated February eight.
68, the Orangeburg Massacre.
We refused to talk about
June of that year or RFK was shot
or the fact
that you have all of these black soldiers
coming home from a war in Vietnam
being treated like second class citizens.
That's not
something that is a fairy tale.
That is a history of who we are.
And Ron
DeSantis is
and this administration in Florida
are completely ignorant to that fact.
Everything we talk about,
about our history
and who we are is not critical
race theory.
My being is not critical. Race theory.
It's American history.
Wrap your hands around that.
If you're ashamed of it, that's on you.
But let's at least educate the youth
the correct way about what our history is
But, Bakari, I'm not arguing with you.
I'm just give you the reasonings
that were put forth by the governor's
office and says
and the letter saying, as presented,
we find this
we find this AP course
doesn't pass our muster.
Please come back with us with the
you know, with another course
or if you'd like to work with us,
we're willing to do that.
I'm not sure they're dismissing it
out of hand is saying
we're not going to do it at all.
David, just politically, does it
do you
does does this work
for Governor DeSantis?
I mean,
is this a popular thing,
you think, for Governor DeSantis
among Republican voters?
In Florida?
Yeah.
Look, I think that the governor. Right.
Has taken up this anti woke
you know, woke comes a day in Florida.
Right.
And it's he's
taken it up pretty pretty aggressively.
I'm not quite sure
that this
may have been rolled out in the best way.
I think a lot of explanation
should be a little bit more explaining.
Should've been done on this
because I don't think it's being it's
dismissing the AP course out of hand.
I think it's just dismissing
this particular AP course. Right.
It just in general,
AP courses are actually sort
of the most prestigious
in the public education system.
AP courses are
those are the most prestigious courses.
It's actually,
you know, a lot of attention
is actually put into them
and thought is put into them.
They're kind of their advanced placement.
So it's often the students
who have excelled
the most who are able to even qualify
for those courses.
It's interesting
that this is probably the
I mean, I don't know how many AP courses
the DeSantis administration
is taking issue with,
but I probably guessing not any others
I would I would
I would guess that you're correct.
And again,
you know,
I think that there's you know,
it could use better articulation.
Again, I don't think that
the Sanders administration
look, I'm not speaking for them.
I'm just taking this letter
and interpreting what it says and saying
I believe that they say
as presented this course
didn't pass muster
in the law that we just passed.
Come back again
and we're willing to sit down and talk.
Right.
David Perry Sellars,
we'll see what happens, if anything.
Thank you.